tf1 20 heures avec roger j call bonsoir
la france a peur je crois qu'on peut le
dire aussi nettement
la france connaît la panique depuis
qu'hier soir une vingtaine de minutes
après la fin de ce journal on lui a
appris cette horreur un enfant est mort
c'est maintenant que nous allons agir
ensemble pour vérifier quelque chose
c'est dans quelques minutes que nous
allons éteindre ensemble les lumières
que nous avons laissés allumés
même quand elles ne sont pas
indispensables je vous ai demandé tout à
l'heure de laisser allumer les lumières
chez vous comme d'habitude et le moment
est venu de s'apprêter à les éteindre
et auparavant nous allons rejoindre
michel chevalet qui se trouve au centre
de distribution d'electricité de france
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure devant ses
cadrans et c'est avec lui que nous
allons regarder ses cadres michel
chevalet à vous eh bien oui roger
gicquel vous voyez en ce moment comme
moi sur votre écran justement ce fameux
compteurs sur lequel va s'enregistrer
n'ont pas encore une fois la
consommation d'électricité des français
en ce moment mais la variation de
consommation donc et nous nous attendons
votre feu vert votre top pour voir cette
aiguille se déplacer dans ce sens là
c'est à dire que les français consomment
au moins ou autrement dit à ce moment-là
l'edf sera en surproduction donc roger
gicquel est bien nous attendons votre
top pour que l'expérience des buts nous
sommes prêts à suivre les variations de
la consommation des tris cité des
français alors maintenant voilà ce n'est
pas sans une certaine émotion que vous
la voyez cette lumière oui ce n'est pas
sans une certaine émotion que je vais
éteindre cette lumière et pour que ça
marche pour qu'on voit la consommation
d'électricité des centrales edf là où se
trouve michel chevalet il faut il faut
que vous fassiez le même geste que moi
surtout les interrupteurs que vous avez
laissée allumée depuis le début de ce
journal
toutes proportions gardées c'est que
ceux comme si nous étions dans une
voiture que nous n'avions pas conscience
de notre vitesse et si nous jetons un
coup d'oeil au compteur on s'aperçoit
qu'on est déjà 138 à 140
on lève le pied par prudence et là nous
allons tous s'éteindre en même temps
pour mesurer sur le cadran de l'edf
l'économie qu'on peut faire
si vous êtes prêts je le suis attention
un deux trois éteignons les lumières qui
ne sont pas indispensables
qu'est ce qu'on voit maintenant
eh bien à l'edf rangé je suis comme vous
venez c'est très net l'aiguillât
dépasser le zéro c'est à dire les kylie
production consommation et commence à
grimper allègrement les milliers de
kilowatts mais milliers de kilowatts
d'économie je parle c'est à dire nous en
sommes pour le moment à 25 milliers de
kilowatts
voilà les pluies continuent de montrer
par là je dirais qu'on ne met pas le
pied on n'appuie pas sur l'accélérateur
en relève au contraire on lève le pied
nous en sommes maintenant à 50 milliers
de kilowatts et ce je vous le rappelle
c'est le bilan pour toute la france en
ce moment qu'est ce que ça représente
les milliers de kilos à des milliers de
kilomètres savez l'aller on part le nom
par milliers de kilowatts ici mais on
parle on mégawatts
si vous voulez quand on va atteindre à
peu près là nous en sommes nous avons
dépassé le sens nous sommes à 150
milliers de kilowatts et bien c'est
l'équivalent de la consommation d'une
ville comme nancy ou nice vous voyez que
ce n'est pas du tout du tout négligeable
et là nous je pense sosa yens nous
stabilisons oui en quelque sorte là
c'est la fluctuation en direct de la
consommation des français nous en sommes
arrivés à un peu plus de 150 presque à
175 milliers de kilowatts d'économie
d'électricité avec notre opération
pardonnez moi cette question michel
chevalet c'est pas truqué tout ça je
vous entends pas j'ai une caution
c'est très important ma question le
conteur que nous voyons là il n'est pas
truquée surtout pas il n'est pas
question de truquer les compteurs je
vous donnais une bonne et simple raison
c'est que en ce moment même les gens de
l'odf au dispatching doivent suivre
l'évolution de la consommation pour
adapter sans arrêt les besoins à la
demande
donc il n'est pas du tout question
qu'ils perdent les yeux sur le compteur
de vitesse et là je peux vous dire nous
sommes réellement
en direct et l'aiguillé s'est stabilisé
à 175 milliers de kilowatts d'économie
d'énergie c'est-à-dire que l'on
économise donc l'équivalent de la
consommation d'une ville comme nice ou
nancy ce qui est loin d négligeable ce
que je voudrais rajouter roger gicquel
c'est que ceux-ci cette opération donc
est une réussite pour tf1 une réussite
pour les français grâce à l'edf et la
chance pour l'économie d'énergie
monsieur syrota et bien cette opération
si tous les ménages français l'a réalisé
tous les jours on obtiendrait une
économie bien sûr beaucoup plus
considérable il faudra à peu près
multiplié par trois ses chiffres et à ce
moment là on obtiendrait bien
l'équivalent de l'énergie fournie par
une centrale thermique alors je vais
vous donner encore un chiffre qui va
vous faire rêver même c'est que une
ampoule de 100 watts en moins chez vous
et bien cela fait pour l'année
l'équivalent pour 4 millions de foyers
français et bien ça fait l'équivalent de
la production d'une centrale thermique
c'est à dire rien moins que 275 mille
tonnes de fioul une dernière précision
enfin ce que l'on fait avec les landes
superflu ce que vous avez fait ce soir
il faut le faire aussi avec d'autres
appareils qui se trouve chez vous donc
on peut réaliser des économies dans
d'autres domaines que l'électricité
certainement françois de closets
la morale de l'histoire c'est qu'un
tiers des français peuvent de toute
façon on était dix ans leurs lumières
provoqué une chute de consommation
importante à l'edf c'est un peu comme si
la totalité des français atteignait une
seule ampoule michel chevalet dit et
nous le dira
nous voulions mettre l'accent sur le
gaspillage individuel de l'électricité
ce qui devait aussi ce qui devrait aussi
inciter les pouvoirs publics les
collectivités les communes je ne sais
pas les les
les collectivités industriels qui
laissent leurs bureaux à lui mais à
faire le même geste que viennent de
faire nos amis tf1 oui d'ailleurs vous
en aurez une application avec
comme vous le savez avec l'heure d'été à
entrer en vigueur au début du mois
prochain
ce qu'il faut tout de même bien dire
c'est que ce que nous avons fait ce soir
c'est une opération quelque sorte
halte au gaspillage et encore uniquement
gaspillage individuelle alors l'économie
d'énergie
ce n'est pas seulement la fin du
gaspillage la fin du gaspillage c'est
facile ça ne coûte pas cher et ça
rapporte à chacun de l'argent pour un
peu de discipline mais il faut savoir
que 10 et 1985
la france a prévu d'économiser chaque
année l'équivalent de 45 millions de
tonnes de pétrole
alors 45 millions de tonnes de pétrole
c'est près de la moitié de notre
consommation actuelle de pétrole
alors ça bien sûr ça ne pourra pas se
faire seulement en mettant fin au
gaspillage
il faudra en plus changer nos usines
changer nos fours changer nos
automobiles et cetera donc faire des
investissements très coûteux
il faudra produire des économies
d'énergie donc en un premier temps parce
que c'est raisonnable on arrête le
gaspillage en escomptant il faudra
investir pour les économies d'énergie